It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值授粉季，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个提供顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元一个月。这可真是一个不会错失的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2021, I talked to Katie Milkman, a behavioral scientist at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania, about how to identify and overcome roadblocks that are getting in the way of making the changes you want to see in your life. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with a new episode next week. Change is hard. When you want to make a change in your life, whether it's eating healthier food, starting an exercise program, or saving more money, there are many human foibles that can stand in your way.
在网络高负荷使用期间，Google Fi Wireless 不会遭遇数据流量降速。本期《心理学发言》正在进行暑假休整，因此我们将重播过去一些最受欢迎的节目。在 2021 年，我与宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的行为科学家凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katie Milkman）进行了交流，探讨了如何识别并克服阻碍你实现生活中期望改变的绊脚石。希望你会喜欢这期精选自资料库的节目。我们将在下周带着新节目回归。改变是困难的。当你想要在生活中做出改变时，无论是吃得更健康、开始运动计划还是存下更多钱，都有许多人类的缺点会挡在你的路上。
Impulsivity, laziness, procrastination, or just plain forgetfulness are among them. Libraries are full of books offering multi-step plans and other tactics to inspire a new you. Often, though, these plans fall flat. Our best intentions aren't enough to overcome the roadblocks of human nature that stand in our way. But in recent years, psychologists have begun to look at behavior change from a different angle. Instead of fighting human nature, this research suggests that we should analyze it and then leverage it to work for us rather than against us. What does that mean? What can we learn from the science of behavior change that can help us make the alterations we want to see in our lives?
冲动、懒惰、拖延，或者仅仅是单纯的健忘，都在其中。图书馆里塞满了提供多步骤计划和其他策略的书籍，旨在激发一个全新的你。然而，这些计划往往收效甚微。我们最好的意愿并不足以克服阻碍我们前进的人性绊脚石。但近年来，心理学家开始从另一个角度看待行为改变。这项研究表明，我们不应该与人性对抗，而是应该对其进行分析，然后加以利用，让它为我们服务，而不是与我们作对。这意味着什么？我们能从行为改变的科学中学到什么，从而帮助我们做出生活中希望看到的改变？
And how can organizations, companies, and governments use these insights to nudge whole populations into making better choices? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Katie Milkman, a professor at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania and author of the book How to Change, the Science of Getting from Where You Are to Where You Want to Be. Her research explores how insights from psychology and economics can be harnessed to change
组织、公司和政府又该如何利用这些洞察来引导整个人群做出更好的选择？欢迎收听《心理学发言》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，专门探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院教授凯蒂·米尔克曼博士，她也是《如何改变：从现状到理想状态的科学》一书的作者。她的研究探讨了如何利用心理学和经济学的洞察来促进
people's behavior for the better on both an individual and a global scale. She has explored how relatively simple interventions can help people increase their savings, exercise more, and even get vaccinated among other things. She is co-director of the Behavior Change for Good Initiative at Wharton. She also hosts the Charles Schwab podcast, Choiceology, about the science of decision-making. Dr. Milpman, thank you for joining us today. Thank you so much for having me. So as I said, your book is entitled How to Change, but in the first chapter, you start with a slightly different premise, which is when to change. You make the point that there are some moments in our lives that are particularly conducive to making change. What is your research found? And if you want to make a change in your life, when should you try to do it? I love that you opened with this question because it's one of my favorite topics that I've studied. And actually, it was a question just like the one you asked that started me on, this course. I was visiting Google presenting some of my work on nudges and choice architecture
人们的行为朝着更好的方向改变，无论是个人层面还是全球层面。她探讨了相对简单的干预措施如何帮助人们增加储蓄、进行更多锻炼甚至接种疫苗等。她是沃顿商学院“善用行为改变”倡议（Behavior Change for Good Initiative）的联席主任。她还主持了查尔斯·施瓦布（Charles Schwab）关于决策科学的播客《抉择学》（Choiceology）。米尔克曼博士，非常感谢你今天加入我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我。正如我所说，你的书名为《如何改变》，但在第一章中，你从一个略有不同的前提开始，那就是何时改变。你指出，我们生活中的某些时刻特别有利于做出改变。你的研究发现了什么？如果你想在生活中做出改变，什么时候应该尝试去做？我很高兴你以这个问题开场，因为这是我研究过最喜欢的话题之一。事实上，正是这样一个类似于你刚才提出的问题，让我踏上了这条道路。当时我正在访问谷歌，展示我关于助推和选择架构的一些工作，
and strategies that could be used by HR managers to help their employees make better decisions and, you know, invest in new skills training, wellness programming, et cetera. And I was asked, is there some ideal time to encourage employees to change? And I realized actually there was very little I knew from the academic literature that would help me answer that great question. So I went back to my research team at the University of Pennsylvania, my former student, Heng Chen Dai, who's now a professor at UCLA's Anderson School, and also Jason Reese, who's the head of behavioralize and a Wharton Senior Fellow. We were all really interested in behavior change. We started talking about this question and had really strong intuitions right away about when it might make sense to change. The first thing that came to mind for all of us was that we know people make more resolutions and set more goals around New Year's.
以及人力资源经理可以用来帮助员工做出更好决策的策略，比如投资新技能培训、健康规划等等。有人问我，是否存在某个鼓励员工改变的理想时间？我意识到，实际上学术文献中几乎没有什么知识能帮我回答这个绝佳的问题。于是我回到了宾夕法尼亚大学我的研究团队，包括我的前学生恒辰戴（Heng Chen Dai，音译），她现在是加州大学洛杉矶分校安德森商学院的教授，还有杰森·里斯（Jason Reese），他是 behavioralize 的负责人兼沃顿高级研究员。我们对行为改变都非常感兴趣。我们开始讨论这个问题，并立即对何时改变才合情合理产生了强烈的直觉。我们所有人脑海中浮现的第一件事是，我们知道人们在新年期间会做出更多的决议并设定更多的目标。
right so that was that was well established we weren't coming up with something wildly new there but what we got interested in is whether there was something about that moment that might give us a hint as to other moments in our lives when we might be more open to change and we started reading the literature on autobiographical memory the way people think about time what we learned is that there are moments in our lives that feel like new beginnings and that's because the way we organize time and our memory is as if our life is a series of chapters, and they have sort of beginnings, middles and ends. That's how we think about ourselves, like characters in a book, instead of thinking about time really, truly linearly. And as a result of that,
对，这是众所周知的事情，我们并没有提出什么惊天动地的新东西。但我们感兴趣的是，那个时刻是否存在某种特质，能够给我们一些暗示，让我们了解生命中其他哪些时刻可能会让我们更乐于接受改变。于是我们开始阅读关于自传体记忆的文献，即人们思考时间的方式。我们了解到，在我们生命中有些时刻感觉像是新的开始，这是因为我们组织时间和记忆的方式，就好像我们的人生是一系列章节，它们有着各自的开始、中间和结束。我们就是这样看待自己的，就像书中的角色一样，而不是真正地、纯粹线性地去思考时间。因此，
any moment that feels like a breakpoint can feel like a new beginning to us, anytime we're opening a new chapter for any reason. And what happens at New Year's and what we found happens at some other moments as well is we feel like, you know, because we're closing a chapter, we can say that was the old me who didn't manage to quit smoking last year or didn't manage to go to that skills training workshop. And the new me and the new year, you know, I'm, I'm different and I can do it. So we feel more optimistic. And we've found in our research that other moments that systematically feel like new beginnings to us and lead to a similar optimism and tendency to pursue goals include dates like just the start of a new week, the start of a new
任何感觉像是分水岭的时刻对我们来说都像是新的开始，任何由于某种原因开启新章节的时刻都是如此。在新年时发生的情况，以及我们发现在其他一些时刻也会发生的情况是，我们会觉得，因为我们在合上一章，所以我们可以说，那是去年的那个我，没能戒烟，或者没能去参加那个技能培训研讨会。而新我和新年，你知道的，我不同了，我能做到。所以我们感觉更加乐观。我们的研究发现，其他那些系统性地让我们感觉像新开始并带来类似乐观情绪和追求目标倾向的时刻，还包括一些日期，比如新一周的开始、新
month, the celebration of a birthday, the celebration of certain holidays that we associate with new beginnings. So think more Labor Day and less Valentine's Day. And we've we've shown in our research that people are more likely to do things like visit the gym at these moments, that they're more likely to set goals on a popular goal setting website around these dates that feel like new beginnings. And also if we reach out and say, when would you like to receive reminders to begin pursuing a goal or when would you like to start saving, for instance? And we simply label dates differently. If we label a date as an ordinary day, right, no special label. It's not nearly as attractive as if we give it a label that makes it feel like a new beginning.
一个月的开始、生日的庆祝，以及我们与新开始相关的特定节日的庆祝。比如多想想劳动节，少想想情人节。我们在研究中表明，人们更有可能在这些时刻做一些事情，比如去健身房，他们更有可能在这些感觉像新开始的日期周围，在一个受欢迎的目标设定网站上设定目标。而且，如果我们伸出橄榄枝并询问：“你什么时候想收到开始追求目标的提醒？”或者“比如你什么时候想开始储蓄？”然后我们只是对日期进行不同的贴标签。如果我们把一个日期贴上普通日子的标签，也就是没有特殊的标签。它远不如我们给它贴上一个让它感觉像新开始的标签那么具有吸引力。
So, for example, in one study, we labeled March 20th as the first day of spring in one condition, but not in the other. It's the third Thursday in March. And we see really huge differences when it's labeled as the first day of spring and how attractive it is as a date to start pursuing a goal, for example. So we both see correlationally, sort of naturally people take advantage of these moments when they're looking at when to change, and we can run experiments and show that if we change the labels associated with certain dates and add fresh start labels, dates that feel like a new
因此，例如在一项研究中，我们在一种情况下将 3 月 20 日贴上春分第一天的标签，而在另一种情况下则没有。它只是 3 月的第三个星期四。当它被贴上春分第一天的标签时，我们看到了巨大的差异，比如它作为开始追求目标的日期的吸引力有多大。因此，我们既看到相关性，也就是自然而然地人们在寻找改变的时机时会利用这些时刻，我们也可以进行实验并证明，如果我们改变与某些日期相关的标签并添加“全新开始”的标签（即让人感觉是新
beginning, we see this uptick. So taking that all together, it points to moments that feel like transitions feel like a new beginning of a chapter in our lives, and particularly temporal landmarks that have those features that we've studied include the starts of these calendar cycles. Okay, but that's an external nudge in a sense. Now, what if I want to make a change, but there isn't some obvious fresh start right now? Is there something that I can do for myself that would just create a fresh start? Yeah, it's a wonderful question. First of all, I would say there are so many dates that even though they are external, you can sort of look for the next one and jump on it, right? You know, Monday occurs every seven days, it turns out. So even though you have to wait around for seven days to start, they're fairly frequent. So I do think even with that constraint, they can be useful as moments to sort of lock on to. In terms of whether you can create one for yourself, Heng Chen, who I mentioned my former student, who's, she did some work in her dissertation related to a slightly different kind of fresh start. She calls it a reset. And it's a different way that it's not a temporal
开始的日期），我们就会看到这种上升趋势。因此，总而言之，它指向那些感觉像是转折点的时刻，这些时刻感觉像是我们生活中新一章的开始，特别是具有我们研究过的那些特征的时间路标，包括这些日历周期的开始。好的，但从某种意义上说，这是一种外部助推。现在，如果我想做出改变，但目前并没有什么显而易见的全新开始呢？我能为自己做些什么来创造一个全新开始吗？是的，这是一个极好的问题。首先，我要说的是，有这么多的日期，尽管它们是外部的，但你基本上可以寻找下一个日期并顺势抓住它，对吧？你知道，每七天就会迎来一个周一。所以即使你必须等待七天才能开始，它们的频率也相当高。因此，我认为即使有这个限制，它们也可以作为锁定目标的有用时刻。至于你是否能为自己创造一个，我刚才提到的我的前学生恒辰，她在博士论文中做了一些与稍微不同类型的全新开始相关的工作。她称之为重置（reset）。这是一种不同的方式，它不是一个
landmark that wipes the slate clean, but rather a change in the way we're tracking our performance that can wipe the slate clean. So, for instance, I wear a Fitbit. And every morning, I sort of feel like I have a bit of a fresh start because yesterday I had accumulated, you know, maybe a pathetically low number of steps, maybe a really high number of steps. Either way, I wake up and it says zero again. And that's a reset and a fresh start in a sense.
能一笔勾销的地标，而是我们追踪表现方式的一种改变，它能够一笔勾销过去的表现。例如，我戴着 Fitbit 手表。每天早晨，我都觉得自己得到了一个新的开始，因为昨天我可能积累了少得可怜的步数，或者可能积累了非常多的步数。无论哪种情况，我醒来时它又显示为零。从某种意义上说，这是一个重置和一个全新的开始。
There's all these different ways in which we track our performance, whether it's sales performance, if you're in an organization, whether you're a professional athlete and you're just sort of tracking your stats for the season. And things get reset at different frequencies, grades for six. students, whether it's semester, quarter. So one thing that we may have some more control over, especially if we're tracking ourselves, is when these resets occur. And if we're having a rough time, it turns out resets can be really valuable as a motivator to improve and set goals and do better. Interestingly, her research also finds that resets are harmful, and I think this is very intuitive,
我们追踪表现的方式有各种各样，无论是如果你身处某个组织中的销售业绩，还是你是一名职业运动员，你只是在追踪自己这个赛季的数据。事情在不同的频率下会被重置，比如学生的成绩，无论是按学期还是按季度。因此，我们可以拥有更多掌控权的一点，特别是如果我们自己追踪自己的表现，就是这些重置发生的时间。如果我们正经历一段艰难时期，事实证明重置作为一种改善、设定目标和做得更好的动力会非常有价值。有趣的是，她的研究还发现，重置是有害的，我认为这非常符合直觉，
actually, in cases where we're doing really well. So you want to wipe the slate clean and have a fresh start when things aren't going your way, when you need the motivation to do something you haven't managed to do. But when you're on a role, it's actually disruptive and harmful to have a fresh start. So we do have to use this particular tool with some caution. You started out as an engineering student and you write in the book that in some ways you approach behavior change as an engineering problem. What do you mean by that? Yeah. It's funny to be on this podcast and I'm often labeled a psychologist, you will laugh. I have literally never taken a psychology class in my entire life. My undergraduate degree and PhD are both in engineering. And so that's the,
实际上，在我们表现很好的情况下也是如此。所以当事情不顺心时，当你需要动力去做一些你一直没能做到的事情时，你会想要一笔勾销并获得一个全新的开始。但当你处于上升期时，拥有一个新的开始其实具有破坏性和负面影响。因此，我们在使用这个特定工具时必须保持一定的谨慎。你最初是一名工程系学生，你在书中写到，在某些方面你将行为改变视为一个工程问题。你是什么意思？是的。在这个播客上感觉很有趣，我经常被称为心理学家，你会笑的。我一生中字面意义上从未上过心理学课。我的本科和博士学位都是工程学。所以这就是，
it's a different way of looking at the world. It's sort of looking for problems that you can solve by pulling the right pieces together in order to, you know, plug a hole or fix a gap or improve a structure. That is the way that I was trained to think. And it turns out, I think it's quite a useful way of looking at a lot of psychology problems, especially in my field of behavioral science where we have spent a lot of time documenting errors and judgment, the ways that people make systematic mistakes. But if you want to actually start correcting some of those mistakes, having this engineering mindset, like, you know, how can I build a structure that plugs that hole? How can I fill that gap is a really useful perspective, I think? And I've tried to bring that to my work.
这是一种看待世界的新方式。它有点像寻找那些你可以通过将正确的零件组合在一起，从而堵住一个洞、修复一个缺口或改善一个结构来解决的问题。这就是我受到的思维训练方式。事实证明，我认为这是一种看待许多心理学问题的非常有用方式，尤其是在我所从事的行为科学领域，我们花了很多时间来记录判断上的错误，也就是人们犯下系统性错误的方式。但如果你想真正开始纠正其中一些错误，拥有这种工程学思维方式，比如“我如何建立一个能够堵住那个洞的结构？我如何填补那个缺口？”我认为这是一个非常实用的视角。我一直试图将这一点带入我的工作中。
I've always been solutions oriented and looking for ways that what we need. know about the human mind not only presents conundrums and puzzles and problems and exposes limits, but also what we can do to actually overcome and build and grow and bridge those gaps. So some of your first research on behavior change was what you call temptation bundling, the idea for which came from something, a problem that you were trying to solve in your own life. Can you tell us that story and explain what temptation bundling is and how it can and help people change their behavior. Yeah, I would love to.
我一直以解决方案为导向，寻找我们所需要的东西。我们对人类心灵的了解不仅呈现出各种难题、谜题、问题并暴露出局限性，而且还能让我们知道如何做才能真正克服、建立、成长并弥合这些差距。因此，你关于行为改变的一些早期研究就是你所说的“诱惑捆绑”（temptation bundling），这个概念的灵感来自于你在自己的生活中试图解决的一个问题。你能给我们讲讲这个故事，并解释什么是“诱惑捆绑”以及它是如何帮助人们改变行为的吗？是的，我很乐意。这
This is absolutely me search, which is a term I'm borrowing. I think another psychologist named Carrie Morwidge is the person who taught me that term. I love that term. It's what drew me into the field, honestly, was that I was doing some me search. So I was a graduate student at the time in engineering and struggling with tough classes and tired at the end of a long day. and all I wanted to do when I came home and should have been working on problem sets was curl up on my couch with, you know, entertainment, a juicy page turner or binge watch Netflix, one of the above.
绝对是“自我研究”（me search），这是一个我借用的术语。我认为另一位名叫卡里·莫维奇（Carrie Morwidge）的心理学家是教给我这个词的人。我喜欢这个词。老实说，正是这一点把我吸引到了这个领域，因为我当时在做一些自我研究。那时我是工程系的一名研究生，正苦于应付艰难的课程，在漫长的一天结束时感到筋疲力尽。而当我回到家本该致力于处理习题集时，我唯一想做的事就是在沙发上蜷缩起来，享受娱乐活动，比如看一本引人入胜的小说或者疯狂刷 Netflix，二者必居其一。
I was struggling to find the motivation to get my work done. Similarly, I knew that I really needed to exercise regularly. It was important for my physical and mental health. I was a lifelong athlete, but I just could not drag myself to the gym. And especially at the end of those long days when I was feeling more in. out. I sort of had this epiphany, a little me search. And by the way, many other people have had this epiphany independently, which was, what if I only let myself enjoy these indulgent entertainment sources while I'm exercising? Maybe that would actually drag me to the gym. And so,
我很难找到动力去完成工作。同样地，我知道我真的需要定期锻炼。这对我的身心健康很重要。我是一名终生运动的运动员，但我就是无法把自己拖去健身房。特别是在那些漫长一天的末尾，当我感觉更加筋疲力尽时。我突然有了这个顿悟，一次小小的自我研究。顺便说一句，许多其他人也独立地有了这个顿悟，那就是：如果我只允许自己在锻炼的同时享受这些纵容式的娱乐来源呢？也许这实际上会把我拖去健身房。所以，
and maybe also I'd stop wasting time at home, binge watching TV when I should have been doing my problem sets. So I tried this out. I made a new rule that I was only allowed to indulge in entertainment while I was exercising. And it was life altering. All of a sudden, I'd come home. home from a long day and all I wanted to do was rush to the gym to find out what happened and the latest. I was actually, I got into audio books, lowbrow audio books like, well, this isn't very lowbrow. Harry Potter, James Patterson, you know, The Hunger Games, page turners, thrillers. I would, I would want to know what happened next to these characters. So I'd dash off to the gym. I'd get in these great workouts where I didn't even notice that I was
也许我也会停止在家疯狂看电视、浪费时间，而本该去做习题集的时候却在摸鱼。于是我尝试了这一点。我制定了一条新规则，即我只被允许在锻炼时放纵自己享受娱乐。这改变了我的生活。突然之间，我结束了漫长的一天回到家，脑子里唯一的愿望就是冲向健身房，去看看接下来发生了什么。我其实迷上了有声书，一些通俗的有声书，比如，嗯，这其实也不算太通俗。哈利·波特、詹姆斯·帕特森，你知道的，饥饿游戏，让人翻页不释卷的小说，惊悚小说。我总是很想知道这些角色的命运如何。所以我冲向健身房。我在那里进行了很棒的锻炼，甚至都没有注意到我在
exercising the time was flying so fast. Normally exercise was a drag, but I was so into the these characters and the stories I kept going. And then I'd come home and I was totally refreshed and rejuvenated, ready to get my work done and there's no distractions. And I thought, wow, this is really working for me. And I should see if this could help other people. So I ended up doing some experiments to test whether or not what I now call temptation bundling or linking something that you find a pleasure and a temptation with an activity that would otherwise feel like a chore in order to make it more, you know, endurable and more pleasant could help people. So we've run a couple of experiments now showing that temptation bundling can be a helpful tool to other people,
锻炼，时间飞逝。通常锻炼是一种折磨，但我太沉迷于这些角色和故事了，我一直坚持下去。然后我回到家，整个人完全神清气爽、焕发活力，准备好完成工作，没有任何分心。我想，哇，这对我真的很管用。我应该看看这能否帮助其他人。所以我最终做了一些实验来测试我如今所说的“诱惑捆绑”是否能提供帮助。“诱惑捆绑”是将你觉得是一种快乐和诱惑的事物与一项原本感觉像杂务的活动联系起来，从而使其更具忍耐力、更加愉快，以此帮助人们。因此，我们现在已经做了一些实验，表明“诱惑捆绑”可以成为帮助其他人的有用工具，
not just me, not an end of one. So one experiment, the first one we did, we randomly assigned people to a group where they would be given tempting audio novels that they could load onto iPods and then listen to the first 30 minutes while they were doing a workout at the gym. And we told them if they wanted to hear what happened next in whichever tempting novel they'd picked from a menu of 80 we gave them that had been pre-tested, well, they would have to come back to the gym because we'd be holding their iPod hostage in a locked, monitored locker. They could only access when they came in for a workout. And we compared that group's exercise habits to a control group that also did a 30-minute workout at the start, also owned iPods, was also given an equally valued gift, a gift certificate to Barnes & Noble,
而不仅仅是我，不仅仅是个例。因此，在一项实验中，也就是我们做的第一个实验，我们随机指派人们进入一个小组，他们会得到诱人的有声小说，可以将其加载到 iPod 上，然后在健身房锻炼时收听前 30 分钟。我们告诉他们，如果他们想从我们提供的一份包含 80 本经过预先测试的菜单中选择的诱人小说里听到接下来发生了什么，好吧，他们必须回到健身房，因为我们会把他们的 iPod 锁在一个有人看守的储物柜里作为“人质”。只有当他们进来锻炼时，他们才能接触到。我们将该组的锻炼习惯与一个对照组进行了比较，对照组一开始也进行了 30 分钟的锻炼，同样拥有 iPod，也获得了同等价值的礼物——巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）的礼品卡，
which they could, of course, used to buy audiobooks if they wanted. But we gave them no suggestion to Temptation Bundle. And what we found is that temptation bundling did increase increased exercise pretty substantially in the short term. So the study went for 10 weeks. The effects were robust for seven weeks. Then along came Thanksgiving break. We did the city university gym. The gym closed. Everybody went home. And this was actually, I think, another interesting part of the research, the effect was totally wiped out by that period of forced separation from the tempting stimulus. So, you know, we've done subsequent studies where we show it can have a more durable affect when you don't have that kind of disruption, but it also links back to what we were talking
当然，如果他们愿意，完全可以用来买有声书。但我们并没有建议他们进行诱惑捆绑。我们发现，诱惑捆绑确实在短期内大幅增加了锻炼。这项研究持续了10周，效果持续了整整七周。接着感恩节假期来了。我们在城市大学的健身房，健身房关门了，大家都回家了。实际上，我认为这是这项研究中另一个有趣的部分，这种与诱惑性刺激的被迫隔离期彻底消除了这一效果。所以，你知道的，我们做过后续研究，表明当没有这种中断时，它可以产生更持久的影响，但这也回到了我们之前讨论的
about with fresh starts and how resets and disruption can be good in some cases, but when you're on a role can be harmful. You get kind of dependent then on your iPod in order to go to the gym if you don't have it when you go back home. Forget it. I'm done. Exactly. Exactly. And there's anyway, all these things I think part of what makes them so interesting is there's there are few things that are just sort of totally unambiguous, always work. There's no moderators. And that's one of the things that's so interesting about studying humans is that there's always interesting complexity to unpack. Anyway, so that's the work on temptation bundling.
关于全新开始的话题，以及重置和中断在某些情况下可能是好的，但在你正处于顺境时可能会有负面影响。当你回家时如果没有它，你会有点依赖你的iPod去健身房。算了吧，我不练了。确实，确实。而且不管怎样，所有这些事情，我认为它们之所以如此有趣的部分原因在于，很少有事情是完全明确的、总是奏效的，也没有调节变量。这也是研究人类如此有趣的原因之一，总是有有趣的复杂性需要去剖析。总之，这就是关于诱惑捆绑的研究。
And I've talked about it only in the context of exercise, but just want to point out for listeners who have other kinds of behaviors that they find to be chores or burdens and they're trying to engage in more, it's a tool that theoretically should be applicable to lots of settings in life, not just getting yourself to the gym. So you can think about, you know, only letting yourself listen to your favorite podcast, say this one while you're doing household chores or cooking fresh meals, if those are goals that you want to fulfill, or only letting yourself pick up a favorite treat or snack on the way to hit the books at the library, if that feels like a chore, but you want something to make it more of a pleasure.
我只在锻炼的语境下谈过它，但我想向那些有其他被视为家务或负担的行为并正试图增加这些行为的听众指出，理论上它应该适用于生活中的许多场景，而不仅仅是去健身房。所以你可以考虑，比如，只有在做家务或做新鲜饭菜时才让自己听最喜欢的播客（比如这个），如果这些是你想要实现的目标，或者在去图书馆啃书的路上才允许自己买一份最喜欢的零食或点心，如果这感觉像是一项苦差事，但你希望有什么东西能让它变得更有趣。
So there's lots of ways we can create temptation bundles beyond exercise, but that is where I first did it and studied it. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas. grill on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price in valid May 14th or May 27th, US-only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
因此，除了锻炼之外，我们还可以通过许多方式创造诱惑捆绑，但这正是我最初进行研究的地方。家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销让你的夏天现在开始。是时候用Next Grills四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需199美元，并用仅售499美元的Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅尽情招待整个季节。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受最低价格保证。活动时间为5月14日至5月27日，数量有限，仅限美国，特定条款适用。详情请参见Home Depot.com斜杠price match。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。够到迷路了。或者你也可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨房间，距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. So your book is organized into chapters, each covering a different aspect of human nature,
希尔顿大促正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿App上预订，最高可省20%，获得您期望的住宿。当您需要省钱而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿伴您好梦连连。所以你的书是按章节组织的，每一章涵盖人性的不同方面，
a couple of which I mentioned in the introduction, impulsivity, laziness, procrastination. Can you talk about your favorite examples from the book about how we can work with rather than against these traits when we're trying to make change? Yeah, probably my favorite example is one that is, it's really well known, and yet it's so important, so I'm just going to harp on it anyway. I think it's the power of defaults. And I think this is one of the biggest wins from behavioral science and it has to do with laziness.
我在引言中提到了其中几个，冲动、懒惰、拖延。你能谈谈书中你最喜欢的例子，关于我们在试图做出改变时，如何顺应而不是对抗这些特质吗？是的，可能我最喜欢的例子是一个非常知名却又如此重要的例子，所以我无论如何都要唠叨一下。我认为这就是默认选项的力量。我认为这是行为科学取得的最大胜利之一，它与懒惰有关。
So in general, we humans prefer to take the path of least resistance, whatever the easiest route is to, you know, collecting my paycheck or getting my lunch or, you know, whatever it is, whatever goal you have, we're always looking for the shortcuts in the easiest way instead of the hardest work path. And that actually, of course, is a challenge, right? when it comes to trying to get yourself in great physical shape or, you know, earning your PhD, the fact that we're looking for shortcuts does not really help, right? It's often a barrier to change. And so I talk a lot about that in the book.
所以总的来说，我们人类更喜欢走阻力最小的路线，无论最简单的路线是去领取薪水、吃午餐，还是无论什么，无论你有什么目标，我们总是在寻找捷径和最简便的方法，而不是最艰难的工作道路。当然，这实际上是一个挑战，对吧？当你想让自己保持极佳的身体状态，或者获得博士学位时，我们寻找捷径的事实并没有真正的帮助，对吧？它通常是改变的障碍。所以我经常在书中谈到这一点。
But one of the things that's so interesting is that defaults, flip this on its head and turn laziness into an asset. So a default is the sort of option you will end up with in a situation if you literally don't lift a finger, if you do nothing. So your computer comes with default settings, right? You turn it on. It has some background screen. It has default fonts. It probably has a default browser. There's all these things that are just there. And if you take the path of least resistance, well, that's what you end up with. And so I think one of the really interesting things is once you start to recognize their power and they've been studied in so many different contexts, it's actually not something I've studied, but lots of wonderful scholars in this association have. I'll just mention.
但非常有趣的一点是，默认选项颠倒了这一点，将懒惰变成了一种资产。默认选项是指你在一个情境中，如果字面意义上不抬一下手指、什么都不做，最终会得到的选项。所以你的电脑自带默认设置，对吧？你打开它，它有一些背景屏幕，它有默认字体，它可能有一个默认浏览器。所有这些东西就摆在那里。如果你选择阻力最小的路线，嗯，这就是你最终得到的。所以我认为非常有趣的一点是，一旦你开始认识到它们的力量，而且它们已经在许多不同的语境中被研究过，这其实不是我研究过的东西，但这个协会里有很多出色的学者研究过。我只提一下。
For instance, Eric Johnson and Dan Goldstein have some wonderful work on how much default organ donation policies change our decisions. So countries where you're defaulted into being an organ donor, but you can just opt out trivially easily by sort of checking a box and signing your name on a basic form, have vastly higher rates of organ donorship than countries where you have to, I said it the wrong way. No, I said it the right way, where you have to opt in, which is what we have in the United States. So in the United States, you go to the DMV, you check a box, you opt in. It's trivially easy, but we have lower donation rates because I had to take some action, and we always look for the path of least resistance. So anyway, this is, organ donation is a particularly tricky one because it's more than just whether you sign your name and check a box and or opt in or opted out that determines
例如，埃里克·约翰逊和丹·戈尔施泰因有一些非常出色的研究，关于默认器官捐赠政策能在多大程度上改变我们的决定。有些国家的政策默认你是器官捐赠者，但你可以通过勾选一个框并在基本表格上签名来极其轻松地退出，这些国家的器官捐赠率远高于那些你必须——我刚才说反了。不，我说对了，那些你必须选择加入的国家，也就是我们在美国的做法。所以在美国，你去机动车辆管理局，勾选一个框，你选择加入。这极其简单，但我们的捐赠率较低，因为我必须采取一些行动，而我们总是寻找阻力最小的路线。所以无论如何，器官捐赠是一个特别棘手的问题，因为它不仅仅是你是否签名勾选或选择加入或退出，决定了
what actually happens with organs. But it shows the power because of these huge differences of a default policy and how important it is to put deep thought into that if you want to change behavior in a positive direction. So when we have defaults that are structured to help people achieve their goals, right, we default them into getting apple slices with their meal instead of French fries on the side. Or we default people into, say, being organ donors, although again, that one has some complexity. All of those choices, they use laziness to help us achieve a goal. So for instance, my browser's homepage is not Facebook or Twitter.
器官最终会发生什么。但它由于默认政策的这些巨大差异展示了力量，以及如果你想朝着积极的方向改变行为，深入思考这一点是多么重要。因此，当我们拥有旨在帮助人们实现其目标的默认设置时，对吧，我们默认他们在用餐时配上苹果片而不是炸薯条。或者我们默认人们成为器官捐赠者，尽管再次强调，那一个有一定的复杂性。所有这些选择，它们利用懒惰来帮助我们实现目标。例如，我的浏览器的首页不是Facebook或Twitter。
It's The New York Times. So every day I encounter some news when I open it up and I don't get sucked into a vortex of something that maybe I'm going to be tempted to waste time with. Instead, I'm getting something that I consider enriching. There's defaults you can have in your pantry in terms of what foods you keep on hand so that it's hard to get the burger and fries or the pizza that you crave that aren't as good for you. If you want to stay healthy, you don't have the cookies in the pantry, you have healthy snacks. And now your defaults and the path of least resistance is aligned with your goals. So I think that's a really powerful tool we can use to set ourselves up for success once we understand the power of laziness and that we can use it and harness it to our benefit. And that's a great one to get people to save as well.
而是《纽约时报》。所以每天当我打开它时，我都会遇到一些新闻，而不会陷入某种我可能会受到诱惑去浪费时间的漩涡中。相反，我得到的是我认为丰富的内容。你在储藏室里可以设置默认选项，关于你手头保存什么食物，这样你就很难买到你渴望的、对你身体不太好的汉堡、薯条或披萨。如果你想保持健康，你的储藏室里就没有饼干，而是健康的零食。现在你的默认选项和阻力最小的路线与你的目标保持一致。所以我认为这是一个非常强大的工具，一旦我们了解了懒惰的力量，并且知道我们可以利用它并为我们所用，我们就可以用它来为成功奠定基础。这也是让人们存钱的一个绝佳工具。
I mean, it always amazes me that every employer doesn't like automatically enroll you in the 401k plan. You know, you won't notice it, right? And I think you've done some work in that area as well. Absolutely. Probably one of the most famous examples and most useful examples besides the organ donation is that employers, and this is worked by Bridget Madrian and Denescia that first showed this in about, I think, 2003, when one employer switched from having new employees enroll by checking a box and signing their name and they'd start having a portion of every paycheck sent to their savings account. They just made a little change in the paperwork, and now you had to check a box and sign your name to say, I don't want that done. And overnight, they saw almost a 40% increase in enrollment in their 401k program, which led to huge increases in people's savings for retirement. And so now it's actually tax advantage for companies to make savings in their 401K's the default. There was a, and the 2006 Pension Protection Act, I believe, passed that that was nonpartisan. Just everyone agreed, let's harness
我的意思是，我总是感到惊奇的是，为什么每个雇主都不会自动帮你注册401k计划。你知道的，你不会注意到它，对吧？我想你也在那个领域做过一些研究。绝对的。除了器官捐赠之外，最著名和最有用的例子之一可能是，雇主们——这是布里奇特·马德里安和德内西亚的研究，大约在2003年首次展示了这一点——当时有一家雇主改变了新员工的注册方式，不再需要勾选框并签名，然后将每笔薪水的一部分发送到储蓄账户。他们只是在纸质文件上做了一点小小的改动，现在你必须勾选一个框并签名来表示“我不想这样做”。一夜之间，他们发现401k计划的注册率增加了近40%，这导致人们的退休储蓄大幅增加。所以现在公司将401k储蓄设为默认选项实际上是有税收优势的。有一个，我相信2006年的《养老金保护法案》通过了这一条款，这是两党一致的。每个人都同意，让我们利用
laziness to make sure that Americans have better financial security. And so it's a terrific example of a tool that policy makers can use. We can certainly also use it ourselves. Like you can go into almost any bank account today and create a recurring deduction from one, or movement from one to another. And once you've set it once, you'll never think about it again.
懒惰来确保美国人拥有更好的财务安全。这是一个政策制定者可以使用的绝佳工具。我们当然也可以自己使用它。就像你今天几乎可以进入任何银行账户，在一个账户和另一个账户之间创建循环扣款或转账。一旦你设置了一次，你就再也不会去想它了。
No one's ever going and changing these things, right? Because you're lazier on the path of least resistance. So if you're just one time, maybe at one fresh start when you're feeling motivated to increase your savings rate, you set up that auto deduction from every paycheck into a savings account that you don't touch. you are going to accumulate more. So that's a really powerful tool. That raises a question around
没有人会去改变这些东西，对吧？因为在阻力最小的路线上面你更懒。所以如果你只有一次，也许在某个你感到有动力提高储蓄率的全新开始时，你设置了从每笔工资自动扣款到一个你不会动用的储蓄账户，你将会积攒更多。所以这是一个非常强大的工具。这就引发了一个问题，关于
how an individual can identify strategies that are going to work in a particular situation. I mean, how, for the listener who wants to make a change, what should they be going through mentally in order to find that strategy that's going to work for them? Yeah, I love that question. Honestly, that is the very question that I would say to some degree was the impetus for writing the book, is that I felt like what I'd realized is, uh, when I talked to individuals, when I talked to organizations that were looking at behavior change challenges, which is what I often do in my research, there was this tendency to just sort of look for off-the-shelf solutions that sounded good and, like, you know, maybe they'd been proven effective in some other
个人如何识别在特定情况下起作用的策略。我的意思是，对于想要做出改变的听众来说，他们应该在心理上经历什么，才能找到适合他们的策略？是的，我喜欢这个问题。老实说，这正是促成这本书的初衷，我觉得我意识到的是，呃，当我与个人交谈时，当我与那些面临行为改变挑战的组织交谈时——这也是我经常在研究中所做的——有一种倾向，就是寻找听起来不错的现成解决方案，就像，你知道的，也许它们在其他某种
situation, but there was very little effort made to diagnose what was the barrier to change. So there wasn't this matching. Like there wasn't an appreciation that it mattered that you understood what was obstructing you in order to choose the right tool to overcome that challenge. And so I tried to write this book to actually, you know, both share everything I knew about the science and behavior change after our career spending it, but also I organized it around,
情况中已被证明有效，但几乎没有花什么力气去诊断改变的障碍是什么。所以没有这种匹配。就像没有意识到理解是什么在阻碍你，对于选择正确的工具来克服这个挑战是很重要的一样。所以我试着写这本书来实际，你知道的，既分享我职业生涯中积累的关于科学和行为改变的所有知识，我也围绕以下内容组织了它：
okay, there are a set of pretty predictable barriers that are actually very recognizable when you, when you are facing a problem, you will pretty easily, once you sort of have read the book or read through this list, you'll say, oh yeah, like, that's a forgetting problem. I'm not, the reason I'm not taking my medications at night
好吧，有一套相当可预测的障碍，当你面临问题时，它们实际上非常容易识别，一旦你读了这本书或看过了这份清单，你就会很容易地说，哦，是的，那是一个遗忘的问题。我不是，我晚上不吃药的原因
is I always forget. It's not that they have awful side effects and it's miserable. It's not that I'm procrastinating because I'd rather do it tomorrow than today. That's a forgetting problem. Sort of once you recognize the types of problems that are systematic, it's actually very easy to see and diagnose what kind of barrier you are facing to change. And then once you know it, there's a whole lot of science that suggests, okay, if it's a forgetting problem here, the kinds of reminders that work here, the tools and strategies. But if it's a barrier of procrastination, you need a really different, different suite of strategies. So I would say actually the diagnosis part is as simple as having a little bit of exposure
是我总是忘记。并不是因为它们有可怕的副作用而且让人痛苦。也不是因为我在拖延，因为我宁愿明天做而不是今天做。那是一个遗忘问题的表现。某种程度上，一旦你认识到这些系统性问题的类型，其实非常容易看到并诊断你正在面临什么样的改变障碍。一旦你知道了，就会有大量的科学研究表明，好吧，如果这是一个遗忘问题，这里有起作用的提醒类型、工具和策略。但如果它是拖延的障碍，你需要一套真正不同、截然不同的策略。所以我实际上会说，诊断部分就像有一点接触一样简单，
and the book that I wrote provides that, but, you know, getting a master's in psychology or even picking up a textbook and learning about the judgment decision-making literature. It's not hard or complex at all. It's just a step we normally skip. We normally go right for the, oh, you know, I'm not achieving my goals. I must need to, you know, build tiny habits. I must need to set bigger, more audacious goals or visualize success instead of thinking, wait, okay, first before I try to solve this problem, what is the barrier?
而我写的这本书提供了这一点，但是，你知道的，获得心理学硕士学位，甚至拿起一本教科书了解判断决策文献。这其实一点也不难或复杂。这只是我们通常会跳过的一个步骤。我们通常直奔主题，哦，你知道的，我没有实现我的目标。我一定需要，你知道的，建立微小习惯。我一定需要设定更大、更宏大的目标，或者把成功可视化，而不是去想，等等，好吧，在我试图解决这个问题之前，障碍到底是什么？
And the barrier is going to guide me towards the right solution because there are many solutions. There's a whole slew of them. As you said, there's self-help books all over the place. And lots of their solutions are science-based, I should say. It's just rarely do they get into like, oh, this only, you know, this is really a solution for this type of problem. What about peer support and the idea of making a commitment to another person? I mean, if you're held accountable somehow, are you then more likely to follow through? Yes. I'm like, this is the easiest answer I get to give you. Just yes. Yeah, let's move on.
障碍将引导我走向正确的解决方案，因为有许多解决方案。有整整一大堆。正如你所说，到处都是自助书。而且我应该说，它们的许多解决方案都是基于科学的。只是很少有书会深入到像，“哦，这只是，这真的是针对这种类型的问题的解决方案”。关于同伴支持以及向另一个人做出承诺的想法呢？我的意思是，如果你以某种方式被追究责任，你接下来就更有可能坚持到底吗？是的。我就像是，这是我能给你的最简单答案。仅仅是“是的”。好吧，我们继续吧。
Yes, of course, it's more complicated than that. But yes, yes, yes. Peer support is so powerful. There's a couple of components of peer support that matter. You touch. on accountability. And accountability absolutely matters because when we basically increase the price of our vice, right, whatever the thing is that's bad for you, like not studying or not saving for retirement or not eating a healthy diet or not, you know, getting your report to your boss in time, if there's a bigger cost, then your general tendency to procrastinate and to prioritize what's fun in the moment instead of what's good for you in the long run. Well, the bigger the cost, the less that is likely to happen, right? So you can up the cost of bad behavior and you'll see less of it. This is
是的，当然，事情比这更复杂。但确实，同伴支持非常有力量。同伴支持有几个重要的组成部分。你提到了责任感。责任感绝对至关重要，因为当我们基本上增加了我们的坏习惯的代价时，对吧，无论对你不好的事情是什么，比如不学习、不为退休储蓄、不吃健康的饮食，或者你知道的，没有按时把报告交给老板，如果付出的代价更大，那么你拖延以及优先考虑当下的快乐而不是长远利益的普遍倾向就会减少。嗯，代价越大，这种情况发生的可能性就越小，对吧？所以你可以提高不良行为的代价，你会发现这种行为减少了。这
very simple math. And one way to up the cost is accountability because shame and feeling that you've let someone else down, those are big costs that we don't like to pay. So absolutely one of the reasons peer support matters is because it can create accountability and it can create those extra costs for failing to follow through. But peer support has a lot of other benefits besides accountability. One of the biggest, I think, which has been studied maybe most impressively by folks like Solomon Ash in the 1950s, and then more recently sort of Robert Chaldeenie has studied social norms. And that is when we look around and see what other people, our peers are doing, what they're achieving, it gives us knowledge about what's normal.
非常简单。提高代价的方法之一就是责任感，因为羞耻感和让你觉得辜负了别人的感觉，都是我们不愿意付出的沉重代价。所以，同伴支持之所以重要，绝对原因之一在于它能创造责任感，并为未能坚持到底的行为带来额外的代价。但除了责任感之外，同伴支持还有许多其他好处。我认为其中最大的一点，已经在很大程度上得到了研究，比如所罗门·阿施在20世纪50年代所做的令人印象深刻的研究，以及最近罗伯特·西奥迪尼对社会规范的研究。那就是，当我们环顾四周，看看其他人、我们的同伴在做什么、他们在取得什么成就时，它让我们知道了什么是正常的。
And that tells us what's possible and what will be rewarded socially, like, you know, how we'll have friends. So you want to fit in. and you actually see what you're capable of in other people's achievements. So not only is there accountability when you have peer groups and you look to those peer groups and they know about your goals, but you can create peer support systems in other ways and you can gain valuable knowledge from your peers about what you can achieve when it comes to goals.
这告诉了我们什么是可能的，以及什么会受到社会的奖励，比如，你知道的，我们如何结交朋友。所以你想融入其中，并且你实际上在别人的成就中看到了自己的潜力。因此，当你拥有同伴群体，并且你关注这些同伴群体，而他们又了解你的目标时，不仅存在责任感，而且你还可以通过其他方式建立同伴支持系统，并从同伴那里获得关于在实现目标时你能取得什么成就的宝贵知识。
So it's really important actually to think carefully if you can, if you have the power to structure your peer group in some way and, you know, moms know this and dads know this too, sorry to be sexist. My husband is a probably more engaged caregiver in many ways than I am shaping our sons, peer groups. So it's really important to think about who you're surrounded with. If you're surrounded with people who are role models who are showing you, this is possible. You know, you want to run marathons. They're running marathons. They're, you know, they're really doing a great job or they're vegetarians. You want to be a vegetarian. That's the kind of lifestyle you aspire to lead. your peers show you the way and they can show you how to get where they are if you look and
所以，如果你有能力以某种方式构建你的同伴群体，仔细思考其实非常重要，而且妈妈们知道这一点，爸爸们也知道这一点，抱歉我有点性别偏见。在塑造我们儿子的同伴群体方面，我的丈夫在很多方面可能是一个比我更投入的照顾者。因此，思考你身边都是些什么人真的非常重要。如果你身边都是那些能给你树立榜样、向你展示“这是可能的”的人。你知道的，你想跑马拉松。他们在跑马拉松。他们，你知道的，他们真的做得很好，或者他们是素食主义者。你想成为一名素食主义者。那是你渴望追求的生活方式。你的同伴会为你指明方向，如果你去寻找，他们就能告诉你如何到达他们所在的地方
you can literally deliberately, strategically copy and paste tactics that they use to successfully achieve their goals. So anyway, that was a long answer after yes, but peer support has a big role to play in behavior change. So that brings me then to vaccine uptake, okay, because a lot of the thinking early in the pandemic once we had vaccines was that peer pressure, peer support, peer example would make people get vaccinated. And we're finding, it works for some people, not for a lot of people. What are we doing wrong? Oh, gosh. We could have a two-hour, we could have a two-day conversation about this. I don't, I don't think we were wrong that peer support social norms would matter for vaccination. I actually think that's true. We just
你可以字面意义上地、刻意地、策略性地复制和粘贴他们用来成功实现目标的战术。不管怎样，在说了“是”之后，这是一个很长的回答，但同伴支持在行为改变中扮演着重要角色。这就把我带到了疫苗接种率的问题上，好吧，因为在大流行初期，一旦我们有了疫苗，许多人的想法就是同伴压力、同伴支持、同伴榜样会促使人们接种疫苗。而我们发现，这对某些人有用，对很多人来说却没用。我们哪里做错了？哦，天哪。我们可以就此进行两个小时、两天的对话。我不知道，我不认为我们在“同伴支持和社会规范对疫苗接种很重要”这一点上是错的。我实际上认为这是真的。我们只是
would have been naive to say, and here I'm coming back to problem solution matching, that for everyone, the barrier was going to be solved by seeing others around them getting vaccinated. Okay. So for some people, the reason you might not get a vaccine might be, well, gosh, this sounds sort of new and scary. I don't know. We'll see if other people do it. If other people do it, and it works out fine for them, maybe I'll feel more comfortable. And their peer norms are going to be really important, seeing lots of, you know, selfies of people you trust or in your community taking this vaccine. That is going to help.
如果说对每个人来说，只要看到周围其他人接种疫苗就能解决障碍，那就太天真了——这里我又回到了问题与解决方案的匹配上。好吧。所以对某些人来说，你可能不接种疫苗的原因可能是，嗯，天哪，这听起来有点新而且吓人。我不知道。我们看看别人做不做。如果别人做了，而且对他们来说结果很好，也许我会觉得更舒服。他们的同伴规范将是非常重要的，看到你信任的人或你社区里的人接种这种疫苗的大量自拍照。那会有所帮助。
And I think that did do a fair amount of work. If you look at surveys from a year ago, last September, only about half of Americans said they would feel comfortable getting a vaccine. And we're, you know, well past, we're past 70% of adults now. having had their first shot, so that's more than half of Americans who had the opportunity to get a shot doing it, right? So we're way better off than we were a year ago, and I suspect part of that. I mean, there's so many things, but part of it may have had to do with seeing their peers, seeing, you know, hundreds of millions of people have done this, and now it feels comfortable.
而且我认为这确实发挥了相当大的作用。如果你看看一年前（去年9月）的调查，只有大约一半的美国人表示他们愿意接种疫苗。而我们现在，你知道的，已经远远超过了，我们现在超过70%的成年人已经接种了第一针，所以这超过了一半有機會接种疫苗的美国人去做了这件事，对吧？所以我们比一年前好多了，我怀疑部分原因。我的意思是，有很多原因，但部分原因可能与看到同伴有关，看到，你知道的，数以亿计的人已经这样做了，现在感觉很舒服。
But the thing is, that wasn't the only barrier. There's misinformation, which is a major barrier. There's another barrier that I think is important to acknowledge, which is cost. There's real cost in terms of time off from work, having child care, having symptoms that is important to acknowledge and recognize, especially in a country where we have so much income inequality, so much inequality of opportunity more generally. And just making something available for free is not covering all of the costs associated with it. So, you know, really wide range of different barriers. and so we need a lot of different solutions to overcome all of that. And of course, it's been politicized, and that didn't help things.
但问题是，这并不是唯一的障碍。还有虚假信息，这是一个主要障碍。还有一个我认为应该承认的重要障碍，那就是成本。在请假误工、寻找育儿帮助、产生副作用等方面存在着真正的成本，这是非常重要且需要承认和认识的，尤其是在一个贫富差距如此之大、机会不平等也如此普遍的国家。仅仅让某事免费并不能涵盖与之相关的所有成本。所以，你知道的，这是一系列非常广泛的不同障碍，因此我们需要许多不同的解决方案来克服所有这些问题。当然，它已经被政治化了，这并没有让事情变得更容易。
And I have lots of brilliant colleagues who could say much smarter things on this podcast about how to tackle that. That's not my specialty, but I do admire the great work being done in this field on the issues of polarization. So what do we do from here? my team has spent a lot of time thinking in the last year and studying this problem and looking at different tactics from we ran some we call them mega studies really really massive randomized controlled trials where instead of testing a single hypothesis we test literally dozens at the same time in parallel we've run these studies with walmart pharmacies and with two large healthcare systems to test out different text messaging communications encouraging people to get a vaccine
而且我有很多才华横溢的同事，他们可以在这个播客上发表更聪明的言论，谈论如何解决这个问题。那不是我的专长，但我确实钦佩在该领域的极化问题上所做的大量出色工作。那么我们接下来该怎么做？过去一年里，我的团队花了很多时间思考和研究这个问题，并研究了各种战术——我们进行了一些我们称之为“巨型研究”的项目，这真的是非常非常庞大的随机对照试验，在这些试验中，我们没有测试单一的假设，而是同时并行测试了数十个假设。我们与沃尔玛药房以及两个大型医疗系统合作开展了这些研究，以测试旨在鼓励人们接种疫苗的不同短信沟通方式
and see what worked best. We found a tactic that did then prove useful. We were studying it in the context of flu shots last fall, hoping it would port over to COVID. And actually, I mentioned Hank Chen Dai when I was talking about flu shot. Excuse me, I was talking about the fresh start. She took sort of a best performer from our two mega studies on flu shots and proved that it then was effective in encouraging COVID-19 vaccinations
看看什么效果最好。我们发现了一种确实证明有用的战术。去年秋天我们在流感疫苗的背景下研究它，希望它能推广到新冠疫苗。事实上，我之前在谈论流感疫苗时提到了戴汉臣（Hank Chen Dai）。对不起，我之前说的是“全新的开始”。她从我们关于流感疫苗的两项巨型研究中挑选了一种表现最好的方法，并证明它随后在鼓励接种COVID-19疫苗方面是有效的
and had a paper about that come out in nature with Sylvia Sicado and some other co-authors in the last couple weeks. And that message was, it's waiting for you, it's reserved for you, it belongs to you, come claim it. So an ownership message sort of conveys recommendation, uses the endowment effect or the fact that we value things more that we feel belong to us. And also probably makes it feel like it's not going to be a hassle because it's already been reserved for you. So I'm not going to have to fight to get mine. All of those things probably are part of what makes it work that we did not study the mechanism we just showed in multiple. large trials that this was sort of the top performer in a big suite of things we tested.
并且在过去几周里，与西尔维娅·西卡多（Sylvia Sicado）和其他一些合著者一起在《自然》杂志上发表了一篇关于该主题的论文。那个信息是：它在等你，它为你保留，它属于你，来领取吧。因此，所有权信息传达了一种推荐，利用了禀赋效应（即我们更珍视那些让我们觉得属于我们的东西）。而且可能也让人觉得这不是一件麻烦事，因为它已经为你保留了。所以我不需要为了得到我的那份而去争取。所有这些因素可能都是它发挥作用的一部分，我们并没有研究其机制，只是在多个大型试验中证明了这是我们测试的一系列方法中的头号赢家。
So we've been recommending using its reserve free language. I don't think at this point in the pandemic that's going to solve the problem with vaccination. I don't think we just need text messages at this point. Yeah. But it's like it's one insight that we, and it may be helpful with things like second shots and booster shots to try to use that optimal language when we communicate about it. And it may counter some of the thinking around the fact that in the beginning it was very hard to get a shot. I mean, it wasn't there.
所以我们一直建议使用“为你保留”的语言。我不认为在大流行的这个阶段，这能解决疫苗接种的问题。我不认为我们在这一点上只需要短信。是的。但这是一个我们可以利用的见解，它可能对第二针和加强针等事情有所帮助，在就此进行沟通时尝试使用这种最佳语言。它可能会反击一些关于大流行初期很难打到疫苗的想法。我的意思是，当时根本没有。
You know, you had to make phone calls and find secret ways to. Yeah. Yes, can I get on your wait list? Could you please call me? I'll call you again tomorrow. Yeah. That's right. So.
你知道的，你不得不打电话寻找秘密的途径。是的。是的，我能加入你们的等待名单吗？你能给我打个电话吗？我明天再给你打电话。是的。没错。所以。
Yeah. But it's a different moment now. And I think we need different tools and tactics. Well, what about making lasting change for the long term? Are you recounted in the book, a conversation you had with a physician friend, were you lamented that in one of your experiments you were able to get participants to go to the gym more often, but the effect wore off when we talked about that a little while ago. And your friend said, we wouldn't expect to give someone with diabetes insulin once and they're cured forever.
是的。但现在是不同的时刻了。我认为我们需要不同的工具和战术。那么，如何为长远做出持久的改变呢？你在书中讲述了你与一位医生朋友的对话，你在其中抱怨说，在你的一个实验中，你能够让参与者更频繁地去健身房，但当我们前一阵子谈到这一点时，这种效果逐渐消失了。你的朋友说，我们不会指望给糖尿病患者注射一次胰岛素，他们的病就永远治好了。
And that makes sense. So what do we have to do to make lasting change? Does a change ever just stick without a conscious effort to maintain it? Yeah. It's a really wonderful question. I wish I had a really simple answer. I think, honestly, this is probably something I'll keep studying for the next, hopefully, 40 years of my life if I eat right and exercise regularly and save well for retirement.
这说得通。那么，我们必须做什么才能做出持久的改变？如果不付出有意识的努力去维持它，改变还会持久吗？会的。这是一个非常精彩的问题。我希望我有一个非常简单的答案。老实说，我认为这可能是我在未来（希望是我生命的头40年里）会继续研究的事情，前提是我饮食健康、经常锻炼并且为退休做好储蓄。
So Kevin Volpe is the scientist who made this great point to me, and it was sort of, oh, glaringly obvious once he said it, but it hadn't clicked for me before he pointed out that we shouldn't be treating behavior change as sort of a one-and-done. like we would find a solution that was magical the way that you want to cure a rash, but that we should think about behavior changes more like facing a chronic disease and trying to look for a suite of solutions because human nature doesn't just turn off, right? All of the barriers to change that I write about in the book, you can't just make them go away. You're going to be struggling with forgetfulness and procrastination and laziness for your whole life.
所以凯文·沃尔佩（Kevin Volpe）就是那个向我提出这个伟大见解的科学家，一旦他指出来，这就显得极其显眼，但在他指出之前，我并没有意识到，我们不应该把行为改变当作那种“一劳永逸”的事情。就好像我们会找到一个神奇的解决方案，就像你想治愈皮疹一样，而我们应该把行为改变更多地看作是面对一种慢性疾病，并试图寻找一套解决方案，因为人性不会就此关闭，对吧？我在书中写的所有关于改变的障碍，你无法让它们凭空消失。你将在你的一生中与健忘、拖延和懒惰作斗争。
I do think there's wonderful research on habits that occasionally suggest that, we can put things on autopilot. And I just want to sort of point to Wendy Wood of University of Southern California as I think the leading thinker in this area. And it does seem that there are certain things that we can put on autopilot to some degree following sort of, you know, the kind of reinforcement we've seen in animal models, right, that you, if you engage in the behavior and then you receive a reward and then you repeat and you do this enough times, certain things do become automatic.
我确实认为，关于习惯的出色研究偶尔表明，我们可以把事情置于自动驾驶状态。我只想指出南加州大学的温迪·伍德（Wendy Wood），我认为她是这一领域的顶尖思想家。而且似乎确实有些事情我们在某种程度上可以置于自动驾驶状态，这遵循了我们在动物模型中看到的强化作用，对吧，如果你参与了某种行为，然后你得到了奖励，然后你重复，你做了足够多次，某些事情确实会变成自动的。
making coffee in the morning or shampooing your hair, flossing your teeth, hand sanitizing if you're a caregiver in a hospital. These are the kinds of things that do seem to be where it is possible to really habituate it and have it for the most part continue. But I think most things require, most of the things we care about in life. And also you can put on autopilot, right, your retirement savings. So there are some magic exceptions. but I do think a lot of the goals we have in life,
比如早上煮咖啡、洗头发、用牙线剔牙，或者如果你是医院的医护人员，进行手部消毒。这些似乎是确实有可能真正养成习惯并在大多数情况下持续下去的事情。但我认为大多数事情都需要，我们需要关心生活中的大多数事情。而且你也可以把退休储蓄置于自动驾驶状态，对吧？所以有一些神奇的例外，但我确实认为我们在生活中拥有的许多目标，
a lot of the things that require effort and thought and deliberation, it's going to be very hard to autopilot them. I'm not sure it's possible. And instead, what I have come to appreciate as the right path to change is to create structures and strategies that you're okay relying on to help you get through the barriers just permanently, right? So, for instance, I still temptation bundled to go to the gym. And that works for me.
许多需要付出努力、思考和深思熟虑的事情，要让它们进入自动驾驶状态是非常困难的。我不确定这是否可能。相反，我逐渐认识到通往改变的正确途径是创建结构和策略，你可以依靠这些策略来帮助你永远克服这些障碍，对吧？例如，我仍然用“诱惑捆绑”法去健身房。这对我很有用。
well, during COVID, I haven't been going to a gym, but to get my exercise in, I look for ways to do that and always will. And I don't feel like I needed to ever end that, that strategy, right? So some of the, I'll call them crutches that we can use to get ourselves to succeed, like accountability or temptation bundling, as we've talked about, there's no need to set them aside. There's no need to say, I'm going to use this for a month. And then I'll be off to the races and I won't need this tactic anymore. Instead, I think we should expect to use them forever and not see that as a downside. It's just that's, you know, we need these tools to achieve our goals and we should keep using them. And that's how we get where we want to be.
嗯，在新冠疫情期间，我一直没去健身房，但为了锻炼身体，我一直在寻找方法，而且以后也会一直这样。我觉得我不需要结束那个策略，对吧？所以有些我称之为“拐杖”的东西，我们可以用它们来促使自己成功，比如我们讨论过的责任感或诱惑捆绑法，没有必要把它们放在一边。没有必要说，我要用这个一个月，然后我就会一飞冲天，再也不需要这个战术了。相反，我认为我们应该指望永远使用它们，并且不要将其视为缺点。这只是，你知道的，我们需要这些工具来达到我们的目标，我们应该继续使用它们。这就是我们如何到达我们想去的地方。
And there's always another good book to listen to. Absolutely. Yes. You'll never run out. That is a wonderful thing about entertainment. There's so much of it. So what next? What are the big questions that you're looking to answer now? Thank you. That's a great question. I mean, the last year has been truly very focused for my team on the issue of vaccination and COVID-19. And we're, you know, working on some papers right now about that. We've been, we launched a vaccine sweepstakes in my hometown of
而且总有另一本好书值得一听。绝对的。是的。你永远不会听完。这是娱乐最棒的一点。有那么多内容。那么接下来呢？你现在希望回答的重大问题是什么？谢谢。这是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，过去一年，我的团队确实非常专注于疫苗接种和COVID-19的问题。我们，你知道的，现在正在撰写一些关于这方面的论文。我们已经，我们在我的家乡
Philadelphia in partnership with the city government that we designed using a regret lottery, which is a very specific type of lottery that, um, capitalizes on people's fear of regret. So everyone in the city was automatically entered and they could get a phone call that their name had been drawn, but they would have to decline the prize if they couldn't prove they'd been vaccinated. So we were, you know, the idea is how much would you regret getting that call, finding out you had won the grand prize and having to decline it, that just that visceral fantasy of the anticipated regret might motivate some extra people to go get a vaccine above and beyond what you'd see in a typical standard lottery
费城与市政府合作发起了一项疫苗抽奖活动，我们使用遗憾彩票进行了设计，这是一种非常特殊的彩票类型，它利用了人们对遗憾的恐惧。所以城里的每个人都自动参与了，他们可能会接到一个电话，说他们的名字被抽中了，但如果他们不能证明自己已经接种了疫苗，他们就必须拒绝这个奖品。所以我们当时想，你会多么后悔接到那个电话，发现自己中了头奖却不得不拒绝它，仅仅是那种对预期遗憾的直观幻想，就可能会激励更多的人去接种疫苗，这超出了你在典型标准彩票中看到的效果
where you're only entered if you're eligible because you've gotten a vaccine. So we've done that and we had sort of randomly assigned zip codes that actually had extra probabilities of winning. So we're working on analyzing that and trying to be able to come out with some policy recommendations for what are the best practices that we can use at this phase in the pandemic. And as we roll out probably booster shots and as other countries reach the phase we've reached. But really looking further forward than the next couple months, I think we sort of touched on it a bit in your prior question. You asked about enduring behavior change. And I still, even though I gave you an answer that I do completely agree with, you know, I believe in very much that the answer is we keep using these tools.
在标准彩票中，只有当你符合资格（因为你已经接种了疫苗）时，你才能参与。所以我们已经做到了这一点，并且我们随机分配了实际上具有更高获胜概率的邮政编码。所以我们正在努力分析这一点，并试图提出一些政策建议，关于我们在大流行的这个阶段可以使用的最佳实践是什么。并且随着我们可能推出加强针以及其他国家达到我们已经到达的阶段。但实际上，比起未来几个月，我看得更远一些，我想我们在你之前的问题中已经稍微触及了这一点。你问过关于持久行为改变的问题。虽然我给你的答案是我完全同意的，你知道的，我非常相信答案是我们继续使用这些工具。
I still study often tactics that an employer or a school or, you know, a gym, you know, an organization that's trying to help people create positive lasting change can wrap around beneficiaries to help them. achieve that durably. And so I'm looking into like what are the tools that those kinds of organizations can offer to their employees, their members, their students that will carry them forward for as long as possible. And what are the kinds of features of programming that make it the most effective? You know, is it mindset? Is it social? Are there other tactics we haven't studied yet that do create more lasting change. So I'm really eager to explore that.
我仍然经常研究雇主、学校或健身房（你知道的，一个试图帮助人们创造积极持久改变的组织）可以围绕受益人提供的战术，以帮助他们持久地实现这一目标。所以我正在研究这些组织可以向其员工、会员、学生提供哪些工具，这些工具将尽可能长时间地推动他们前进。什么样的编程功能使其最有效？你知道的，是心态吗？是社交吗？还有其他我们尚未研究过的、确实能带来更持久改变的战术吗？所以我真的很渴望去探索这一点。
I'm also really interested in understanding better when people have goal failure, how they stand up again. You know, fresh starts are part of it, of course. And there's other tactics in the book, too. But I think recovering from failure is under, it's so important because we almost always fail when we set out to achieve a goal at least once. We have to get back up again if we're going to get to our final destination. And I think there's a lot more to know about how to do that.
我也非常渴望更好地了解当人们目标失败时，他们是如何重新站起来的。你知道的，全新的开始当然是其中的一部分。书中还有其他战术。但我认为从失败中恢复过来被低估了，这太重要了，因为当我们着手实现一个目标时，我们几乎总是至少失败一次。如果我们想到达最终目的地，我们就必须重新站起来。我认为关于如何做到这一点还有很多需要了解的地方。
Well, Dr. Milkman, this has been really interesting. I think you're doing extraordinarily important work, and I want to thank you for joining us today. Thank you so much for having me. This was a really fun conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts, and please, where you can, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
好吧，米尔克曼博士，这次访谈真的非常有趣。我认为你正在做极其重要的工作，我想感谢你今天加入我们。非常感谢邀请我。这是一次非常愉快的对话。你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取喜爱播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目，如果可以的话，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发邮件给我们：speaking of psychology
at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week.
发至 APA.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在 APA.org。Speaking of Psychology 由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的音响编辑是 Chris Kondyen。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的 Kim Mills。在拉尔夫斯（Ralphs）享受更多省钱方式，例如每个货架上的低价。当你下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，你每周还可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。
Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save. and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. C-Sight for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，你还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫斯，每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过省钱和奖励，每天都可以轻松省下大钱。Ralphs SoCal 150多年来一直如此。省钱金额可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请参见网站。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。